there's a question in the chat would
love to hear thoughts on the homosexual
experience and how it integrates into
what we're talking about if you're still
not quote genderless Consciousness if
you're still not that then sometimes
what's happening down at the root is an
identification with being a man it's
like an identification with being your
bi like hardcore like ident it's like a
grip on your identity and also you're
not in that way you're not technically
balanced because you haven't learned
what feminine surrender is
so for the man and I've had I've had a
couple experiences like this that I've
been important where I've been with a
man in both ways in both being
penetrated and penetrating because it's
been the learning of what surrender is
the balancing of into the the with the
feminine polarity and then also it's
then learning how to hold men and be
held by men so that way you don't create
artificial war with your Brothers in the
new world okay so so that's how that's
how it worked out here and then now
obvious like what I am what this is and
then the coming together with the
feminine body right to come together
into the Divine Union that way and the
the codes that come from that so it's
almost like it can come up as an as an
experience in the Journey of the male
body to learn those lessons dissolve
those contractions and the conditionings
around it but don't get quote stuck
there is one way to to put it especially
if you're quote feeling like you're
queer or whatever and you and you're
like playing around with that that then
you can integrate it back into the
Divine Union of the male man and woman
for the the new Earth so that that would
be my response yeah